the face on this clock completely
disintegrated so I used Sketchup to
design a new one and I thought that
would be a cool tutorial so I'll do it
again and record it so here we are in
Sketchup 8 I like to use the older
version because the licensing art is
less restrictive and it can do as much
as the new one I'm gonna draw just a
plane to establish where I'm gonna put
their clock face and let's draw a circle
of 20 centimeters in diameter or 10
centimeters in radius so I'm just
punching in 10 right there and there's
our circle now a circle by default in
Sketchup has 24 segments so if we go
into entity a here and the circle has 24
sides I want that nice and smooth so
let's make it 60 sides and now you can't
really tell that it's made out of
segments I'm gonna take this circle and
I'm gonna make an entity out of it
because I don't want things to stick to
it let's draw a vertical line here to
help me with drawing the divisions for
the hours so I'll draw a rectangle here
and I want that to be centered or on the
top so I'm just gonna select the top
here and move it here and that's an hour
mark and let's make that into an object
as well turning things into objects is a
very useful kind of practice and now I
need the minute marks it's just hover on
the edge of the circle and then
somewhere there so now it's easy to find
the center of that circle because I'll
need to find that many times now I'm
going to rotate this mark by one
sixtieth of a circle this is six degrees
and I want to rotate about the center so
now go like this and I'll hold down
control which copies it and now I punch
in six and there's my first minute mark
and I need those everywhere except for
the hour marks but I want this to be a
bit smaller so the first thing I'm going
to do I'm going to make this unique make
unique and that makes it a new object
because now I can go to this object
I've just opened the object and I'm
gonna make this object a little bit
smaller so I'll take this line down here
drag it up a little bit
and take the sides and bring those in a
little bit too
let's come out of it again no let's
rotate it again to make some more minute
marks let's make the minute marks for
the first hour or so and we rotate it
six degrees again and times three
because I want four of those marks and
let's take that that's the marks for one
hours worth and I'll make that an object
again being strategic about objects is a
very useful thing in Sketchup and now
let's rotate that thing again for the
hours and you know hover on the edge
here and that will allow me just snapped
in the middle of the circle
and I hold down control when I do the
rotate and I type in 30 so there's my
second hour and I want that to go all
the way around so now I punch in down
here times 11 because actually want 11
copies not 1 and there is all of my
divisions on there now what I should
have done is I should have actually made
these things black so I'll use the paint
tool there's a paint tool and I'll
select black and because these are
objects these are all the ones on the
edge of our block and they'll do the
same thing with the minute ones and
these are all copies of the same object
so if I modify one that modifies all of
them we are running into some problem
here because I've got this background
plane that is on the same plane as these
things here but I still want that
background plane to be there but if I
delete that background plane and this
circle you can see these are all there
no I'm just gonna hit backspace to get
to that path again to undo now we also
need some numbers and I'm going to use
the 3d text tool this tool here to draw
some numbers I have this set to 2
centimeters place there's a 1 now how do
I place these well so I'm going to open
this object here and I'm going to draw
just a little circle here
as a guide to where when I place my
numbers and the circle so you'll notice
there's 12 copy this circle now because
I'm actually taking this object that has
12 copies I'll delete the circle later
on but that circle will be useful for
guiding where to place the text tools 3d
text again to get the second one - and
just to be different I'm going to label
the top of the clock with is 0 I think
I'm pretty happy with where my digits
ended up this one may be a little bit
further to the left and it's still
snapping but I'll tell it to move it by
0.05 definitely in the middle so now I
don't need these circles anymore so I'll
just hide that in case I need it again
let's get rid of this background plane
and this part here and we're still
seeing these things a little bit blinky
and that's because these lines are in
the same plane as this background circle
that I drew we could just delete it and
have a clock face but now we have the
background in here so let's go into
window styles and I'll pick a style that
doesn't have a background this one here
and we'll get rid of the oxys and no
longer need these guidelines and to make
sure I'm not the storing this clock face
I'm gonna do camera standard views front
and to be on the safe side we'll also
turn on parallel projection and now I
know I have no distortion and these our
marks look a little bit heavy so I'll
just take that and I'll make that a
little bit smaller
they'll bring the sides in by a little
bit no that snaps that when millimeters
would point one centimeters for me right
now that we have a configurate but I
wanted half of that much so I'll just
enter that number plate over five
centimeters you know drag the other side
in by the same amount it close that
object and there's a clock face and just
to be nerdy I'm gonna color these by the
resistance decade type numbers or colors
so black means zero so I'll take the
pain through and I'll color this one
block and it did the same thing with the
other numbers but I'll spare you the
details on that and there's our clock
face now for printing I don't really
trust Sketchup to actually print what
you see is what you get so to now print
this out I'm going to export this
export so there is the drawing and I'm
going to use a piece of software that I
wrote that actually sell called big
print and I'll drag the clock face into
it and let's crop this to what I need or
see for crop and I know the clock is 19
and a half centimeters across
so I'll just mark the distance on here
as nineteen point five centimeters and
that scales it accordingly and that
tells me that still fits on one page
although I noticed I accidentally
dropped off the top of it you need undo
crop so the scale calibration is still
correct
let's crop that again and now I can
print this I don't have to worry about
the scale thing in here that won't print
so we select print and print again and I
would just click this button I don't
know what kind of inferior paper they
use for this